[Music]
are you familiar with these
parts of the frontier not with this part
not yet
there is an episode of hysteria about
the barbarians
[Music]
i have orders to obtain
i'm speaking of particular situations
situations where i am probing for the
truth
since all is not well here i expect
further measures will be taken
controls are conducting operations to
correct the situation that you've
allowed to develop
what did they do to you you want me to
take you back to
family the barbarians whom you are
chasing
this is their land they know every inch
of it you do not did you really say that
there will be a great war
against the empire pain is truth
that is how you get it you have no idea
how tiresome your behavior is
you are an obscene torture
we have said procedures ready to go
you've been treasonously consulting with
the enemy
get out i want these people out of here
we will end these troubles
we will put down the enemy
and that will be the end of it
[Music]
you